Tom Holland reveals he's been sober for
over a year and opens up about how his
most recent project helped him to
recognize his own triggers this wasn't a
random shooting he's hiding something
what happened in that house where did
they all go
I have these blank spots in the new
Apple TV plus miniseries the crowded
room Tom plays Danny Sullivan a young
man who is arrested for a crime he says
he didn't commit
he never struck you as strange that this
man just showed up to save you
figured I was lucky have you ever been
lucky no and in a new interview with
Entertainment Weekly the Spider-Man no
way home star says he spoke to
psychiatrists in order to better
understand his character adding that
learning about mental health and the
power of it has been something that has
been so informative to my own life Tom
admits the project took a toll on him
and it took a long time to recover and
get back to reality isn't right Danny
may be innocent what are you not telling
me
what are you not telling yourself
after nine months of filming Tom says he
needed to disconnect from his character
for the sake of his mental health I was
seeing myself in him but in my personal
life I remember having a bit of a
meltdown at home it was unlike anything
I've ever experienced before I could be
that's critical of myself I guess Tom
wants viewers to have more respect and
more sympathy for people who are going
through mental health issues after
seeing the crowded room adding that he
hopes people will feel educated about
the powers of mental health the
struggles and our incredible abilities
to survive if that is something that we
can do then I think we've achieved
something really special and while Tom
didn't specify what substance he is
abstaining from he previously discussed
wanting to take a break from alcohol
during an April 2020 virtual appearance
on Jimmy Kimmel Live she's been on
lockdown in London for about a month and
how are you getting along are there any
issues that need to be worked out not
really because we're all drunk all the
time so I actually said this weekend
that I was going to stop drinking for a
week I was gonna have a week off and
then literally Monday morning I've got
my own prop Ryan Reynolds sent me a case
of gin and last year Tom announced he
was taking a step back from social media
to protect his peace I find Instagram
and Twitter to be over stimulating to be
overwhelming I get caught up and I
spiral when I read things about me
online
um
and ultimately it's very detrimental to
to my mental state
so I decided to take a step back and
delete the app now he's back online
promoting his new show and we gotta
applaud Tom for speaking out about
mental health at the moment it's just
enjoying the ride you know I'm really
really lucky to be in this position and
uh I think it's important for me to just
sit back relax and enjoy it because this
is something that I'm only really going
to experience get to experience once and
I just want to enjoy it while I can
[Music]
foreign